this dam wasn't able to stop the monsoon
floods in utter Pradesh where 80% of the
state has been affected there have been
days of heavy rain here forcing many
from their homes our home has been
destroyed and it's ruthless we have no
place to live
my brother uncle's father all of us only
have umbrellas we have been forced into
the streets people in rural areas are
using everything they can to get to
safety relief camps have been set up and
the Indian government has promised to
compensate families of those killed by
the floods the eastern states of Bihar
is no different the damage is extensive
this is the local government building
mostly submerged rescuers have been
working tirelessly to transport people
to temporary relief centers overwhelmed
the state government has called on the
Indian Air Force to airdrop much-needed
food and medication a lot of people have
been affected by the flooding especially
in the low-lying areas the Disaster
Response Teams have evacuated them
almost 9,000 people have been moved
since this morning for those who have
not only just lost their homes but their
livelihoods they'll need a lot more help
this video shared on social media shows
a man who refuses to leave his rickshaw
that earns him a living
he cries as he tries to rescue it most
businesses have come to a halt schools
and some of the worst-hit districts are
closed until Tuesday with some roads and
bridges destroyed it's still not clear
when life for those in the states of
Uttar Pradesh and Bihar will return to
normal
Saira Hyde at al Jazeera